parents are never wrong uh I sleep in
this room like it's my room growing up
and I noticed like this yellow spot on
the floor and so my parents have a lot
of dogs and then my dad comes in and he
goes what are you doing and I'm like
well the dog peed in the room he goes no
they didn't and I'm like Dad I know what
pee smells like this is [__] pee and
so I'm irritated now right I go out my
laptop's on the table I look at my
laptop I smell it one of the dogs pissed
on my laptop oh my God so let me tell
you what my mom does and this is a great
example of how Asian parents never want
to be wrong she looks me dead in the
face right she goes well this is your
fault you're the one who asked for
carpet When We R this house in that room
I
was Ed I was 10 years old you're the one
who wanted carpet I was
10 I was 10 years old I looked at her
dead in the windows of her soul